was one of Islam's most famous and
influential Scholars during the 20th and
early 21st century born in Egypt in 1926
al-carawi memorized the Quran by the age
of 10.
and was giving sermons when he was 16
years old he studied at the
centuries-old al-asahar University of
which many of Sunni Islam's clerics and
Scholars graduate from
in his late teens al-karada we joined
the Muslim Brotherhood eventually
becoming one of its main theological and
religious thinkers and remained so even
after he left the group his membership
of the Brotherhood led him to being
arrested several times both during the
reign of King farook and by the regime
of gamalab the Nasser
by 1961 al-carawi decided to leave Egypt
due to the lack of Freedom there he
arrived in Qatar which eventually became
his home his speeches were now being
eagerly listened to by Muslims across
the region and even further the late
boxing world champion Muhammad Ali
included
we authored more than 120 books which
have been translated into dozens of
languages and his show religion and life
that used to be broadcast on Al Jazeera
was one of the most popular TV programs
in the arabic speaking world the Muslim
scholar was regarded by his followers as
a moderate his religious edicts or
fatwas included Banning female genital
mutilation honor killings condemning the
9 11 World Trade Center attacks and
leading a delegation to Afghanistan in a
bit to convince the Taliban not to
destroy the centuries-old Buddhist
statues in bamian but alakaradawi's
unwavering support for the Palestinians
and their right to self-determination
earned him criticism by Western
governments he was denied a visa to the
UK in 2008 and France also later denied
him entry following campaigns by the
pro-israeli lobbies there
he was also a fierce opponent of
islamophobia heavily criticizing the
French ban on hijab in 2004 and calling
for a boycott of Danish Goods following
the publication of offensive cartoons of
the Prophet Muhammad in 2011
al-qharadawi was among the first to lend
his support to the Arab Spring uprisings
saying that it was forbidden in Islam
for regimes to oppress the people and
that everyone had a right to live in
Freedom it was al-karadawi who gave the
first Friday sermon in Tahir Square
after husn Mubarak was toppled
it was no surprise then that following
the 2013 coup in Egypt the LCC regime
confiscated the scholars assets Tried
Him in absentia and accused him of
inciting terrorism
unable to arrest him because he was out
of the country Egyptian authorities
instead detained his daughter Ola who
remains behind bars in solitary
confinement
AWI founded several institutions in his
lifetime including the international
Union of Muslim Scholars and the
European fatwa Council through these and
his books and sermons his impact is
likely to outlive him with his passing
the Muslim world has lost arguably its
most influential and learned religious
scholar of modern times